salut ça va comme bien des optométristes
marie-eve corbeil est très sollicité ces
jours ci ici ça serait quoi la plus
petite 4 à lire des examens de routine
qui n'ont pu avoir lieu au printemps
dernier mais aussi des yeux fatigués
qu'ils n'ont pas été ménagés pendant le
confinement le télétravail et l'école à
distance cad faible et crack est très
proche proche proche autres mais quand
même assez lointain j'accuse parfait ça
s'est très très bien
on a énormément de témoignages de
parents qui viennent nous voir prises
j'ai perdu le contrôle sur l'utilisation
des tablettes les parents devaient
travailler en mode virtuel les avaient
eux mêmes des réunions effet poète à
tout bout de champ dérangé il y à deux
fois plus d'enfants myope au québec
qu'il y a vingt ans ça commence plutôt
sa touche plus d'enfants ça progresse
plus vite quand l'enfant est plus jeune
et il faut agir le plus rapidement
possible si l'hérédité compte pour 30%
le reste relève du mode de vie
la scolarisation commence plus tôt et le
temps d'écran augmente on line au
téléphone à 18 cm alors que normalement
le y est fait pour lire à 40 centimes
est beaucoup plus fort sans pour le sien
visuel l'oeil s'adapte on est des
animaux qui s'adapte darwin le dit donc
si on passe notre vie à cette distance
le s arrange pour être confortable ça ne
sent cela devient mire la myopie
provoque une élongation de l'oeil
surtout quand elle s'installe tôt
maintenant aujourd'hui à -3 donc c'est
pas 18 ans je les vois arriver c'est à 8
ans et e81 tout me aupic qui apparaît à
21 est un très très grand risque d'avoir
un handicap visuel à l'âge de 60 ans si
on ne fait rien on a tous la même red
sun donc si je deviens plus myope et que
j'ai grandi que je m'allonge donc je
deviens plus important j'étire ci-dessus
là en plus j'allonge plus ma rétine est
fragilisé les optométristes y voit un
problème de santé publique
myopie kipré qui commence tout progresse
jusqu'à la fin de la croissance qui sont
des passes de 6,10 au prix de miami
à long terme c'est plus d'incidence de
maladies des yeux et des maladies galles
de décollement de rétine de glaucome
primature prématuré de dégénérescence
maculaire précoce
la tendance est mondiale si rien n'est
fait dans 25 ans une personne sur deux
sera myope entraînant de grand risque de
cécité à 60 ans pour 10 % d'entre elles
dont il ya 10% de la population mondiale
qui pourrait avoir un handicap visuel
qu'on peut éviter d'ailleurs enchaîné
ont fait une étude ils ont trouvé 5 %
d'augmentation de la myopie chez la même
tranche d'âge surtout chez les plus
jeunes 6 8 en année de pandémie par
rapport à ce qu'ils étaient avant dans
une population qui était déjà mis en
banque c'est extrêmement consommer et ça
prouve donc que notre environnement
technologie et notre environnement de
concentration de broches nous amène à
demi accusations de plus en plus grand
sans tourner le dos à la technologie il
y a des choses simples à faire pour
limiter la progression de la myopie
comme favoriser le visionnement de
vidéos sur un écran de télévision plutôt
que sur une tablette ou encore tout
simplement jouer dehors
on sait que d'aller d'art au moins une
heure par jour protège contre
l'apparition de la meilleure pub il ya
quelque chose dans la lumière du jour
qui vient prévenir le développement de
la myopie donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
va répéter et répéter passé beaucoup de
temps à l'extérieur on peut prédire
qu'il n'y a pas que la santé visuelle
qui s'en portera mieux ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal